we should want to get lunch if you don't
know what a bowl day that is then you
probably haven't lived in New York in
Spanish bodega translates to grocery
store and in New York it's the
neighborhood corner store where you can
get anything from beer to diapers a new
startup called Ava promises the same
convenience as an actual bodega but a
lot of people are not happy about it so
why do we need bodegas that's the beauty
of bodegas you can get tacos in one
place and something completely different
in another neighborhood I've been coming
a Hajis before I'm gonna say since I was
like 11 you can come here and get
anything that you need you come here get
the chopped cheese which is what I'm
getting now
Hajis is known for its famous chopped
cheese we toasted it you get whatever
kind of cheese you like so about maybe
200 maybe 300 sandwiches a day get to
know the people in the neighborhood we
get to know the people that work here to
get to know you people were here being
my friend for more than 30 years say you
won in Colombia Dubai one beer you wanna
planting by one blind date for many
people well they just feel like home
it's about the people and the cats yeah
we go hot drink oh the greatest hangover
each bodega depending on the
neighborhood has something you just
can't get anywhere else
[Music]
they're just some things a machine can't
replace
thanks for coming have a good day
[Music]